deep beneath the Arctic ice something is
trying to escape it breathes fire it's
left its mark all over the globe and it
has the power to completely wipe us off
the planet no we're not talking about
some grotesque monster lurking
underground we're talking about an
invisible gas named methane what would
happen if it escapes the Earth's surface
would it speed up global warming and how
much longer can we keep it contained
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth released all its
methane if earth released all of its
methane it would be bad news for
everyone on the planet
methane is one of the most potent
greenhouse gases with a global warming
potential of up to 84 times higher than
carbon dioxide over a 10 to 20 year
period sure we can limit the amount of
methane that gets released by human
processes like extracting oil but as
long as global temperatures are rising
there's nothing we can do about the
methane deposits that get released as
the Arctic ice melts the last time an
abundance of methane escaped the earth
it led to a mass extinction that wiped
out 90% of the planet's population could
that happen again
you wouldn't know it but methane is
hiding all over our planet it's odorless
colorless and sometimes it can only be
detected if you light a match methane
can be produced through chemical
reactions as organic matter decomposes
in low oxygen environments like bogs or
swamps when plants die and sink to the
bottom of swamps bacteria break them
down and produce methane in the Arctic
water molecules trap the methane
molecules in a kind of chemical cage
called a clathrate they're down on the
ocean floor where the water temperature
and the pressure have kept the methane
from causing problems but as the
temperatures rise the clathrate cages
start to become unstable and release the
methane and water molecules the methane
deposits expand into gas forming bulges
in the bottom of the ocean eventually
these bulges grow and burst releasing
the methane bubbles into our atmosphere
and this isn't the only way that warming
temperatures will release more methane
into the air thanks to global warming in
the Siberian tundra permafrost is
melting this frozen organic material is
like a clathrate and as it melts methane
and carbon dioxide gases are released in
the short term all this methane being
added to our atmosphere would result in
even warmer temperatures and in the long
term it could cause another mass
extinction similar to what happened
during the Permian extinction 250
million years ago the Permian extinction
wiped out 90% of the planet's population
and if the earth continues to release
methane at this rate we would be headed
in the same direction our oceans would
rise significantly and force everyone
near the coasts to move inland
and the warming temperatures would mean
more insect borne diseases like malaria
would be able to travel throughout the
world drought would lead to major food
shortages and intense storms would
continuously bombard our homes and
communities
unfortunately the release of methane is
a cycle that's hard to stop but there
are some things that we can control if
we can get human methane emissions from
things like natural gas leaks and coal
mining under control
the natural methane the earth produces
might not be a major concern that's why
the Environmental Defense Fund has
collaborated with over 140 experts to
measure methane gas pollution worldwide
they believe they can turn that data
into environmental action and could
reduce methane pollution by 40% by the
year 2025 ironically the best thing for
our planet would probably be if our
species was actually wiped out if humans
disappeared from the earth less methane
would be released into the atmosphere
and the climate may return to normal
levels but that's a story for another
what-if